[Music]
hey welcome to dean's office hours
i am so excited this is almost like uh
the closing ceremonies for application
week i hope you have had as great a time
this week as i have um we are joined
today by the assistant dean of nba
admissions and financial aid kristin
moss so just to give a little rundown of
what we're gonna be doing today
easy outline we're gonna quick welcome
from their introduction so we've already
knocked that welcome out we're gonna
have a discussion a fireside chat i love
these conversations uh i get the honor
of getting to work with kirsten
but every time we host one of these i
learned something new and i leave with
that little aha moment that i'm like oh
yeah maybe we could try that let's do
let's do something a little different
and then we'll definitely use the q a
box so as i said before please ask your
questions there we also have a team of
folks online who will be helping behind
the scenes
we'll have about 50 minutes together and
um just so everybody knows these videos
will be posted um there's going to be a
little bit of a short turnaround some of
our events from the beginning of the
week are already posted so if you want
to come back to these ever to refresh on
some different ways to maybe kick start
your process or find moments of
inspiration to get you to that
end of that application to click submit
we are here for it and we will always be
there at your fingertips
so
i'm going to go ahead and stop screen
share
kirsten i know i might have spoiled your
intro a little bit but could you please
introduce yourself and
in similar spirit to the question uh we
asked attendees um how about
uh if you could fill in the blank one of
your professional goals is
that's great thank you will and thank
you for the delightful introduction um
just as it's inspiring to read about all
the students the potential the
applicants who are out there and what
you're passionate about it's fun to be
here and share my own so will an answer
to your question i i feel so fortunate
that i love my job so my post
professional goal or my goal right now
is to keep this job so keep your fingers
crossed that i'll have it for a long
time but more specifically one of the
goals that i know both of us share and
is so important in the last few years
will and i have been talking about how
do we really make our process as
transparent as possible so that whoever
is applying can put their best foot
forward and little by little we've been
trying to crack this nut so i'm really
excited today to have this final session
as we continue to just make it as easy
as possible for anyone listening today
to get to the next step in your own
journey and hopefully you know you'll
consider stanford what can we do to make
sure that you understand how to get here
yeah it's funny how
even from our first discussions and then
as we've seen things evolve um
how we've absorbed in our kind of living
that changed lives change organizations
change the world
just kind of something that you absorb
even by working at the gsb so watching
it happen with our students is
that much more special
yeah and let's not and this is really
the first time that we've ever had an
application week like this before so
huge shout out back to will for his
brainstorm and the entire team who's put
this together we're so excited to
deliver it yeah and like we're talking
about both program but
even internally we're always thinking
about how we can
improve the things that we do and what
we offer including the application i
know you've led um our team in like that
design process um
and
i want to know like
can you provide any insights into your
goals especially as a leader with your
like your vision for where we go next um
what are your goals for the application
and evaluation process
it's a a great question and a way wheel
that brings us it's so easy in the
application because it's complex or how
we evaluate to get down in the details
you know who's your reference who's the
best person to do that or how do i do my
resume um but one of the things that
i've tried to think a lot about at the
highest level is
what are we aiming for when we built
this evaluation system and the
application what was really the angle of
what we're trying to do and if we get
very simplistic for anybody listening
hopefully this will help you as you're
writing your own applications there's
really three things that i think are
most important to us at stanford and one
is we're an educational institution so
the number one thing is we're trying to
find students who are going to be
engaged in that classroom and maybe all
of you can reflect for a moment like go
back to university or even high school
was there a class that you just loved
that you felt alive in where everyone's
hand was up and what was the teacher
like and how did you show up that's what
we're trying to you know the admissions
team is trying to find is is students
who will come into our classrooms and
not only share their own perspectives
but be this curious and excited to learn
and our faculty it'll feed on itself
so
one of the priorities i'm always holding
as we design our application and process
is how do we make sure we're getting
that data so we can find students who
really appreciate learning for
learning's sake so that's one
and then the second thing will already
mentioned our tagline of change lives
change organizations change the world
in some ways that can
sound
i don't know high and mighty like too
hard to achieve the reality is every
time we pick up an application we're
looking for people who will have
positive impact when they go out there
and graduate and it's actually hard you
know we struggle we refine this
application all the time because it's
not as if we're in a company let's say
you're in
consulting right now and you interviewed
there's some skills that someone who's a
consultant needs to have for us we want
leaders to go out across the globe in
every industry and you know whether it's
for-profit or non-profit education it
could be journalism media you know
finance so how do we find those
characteristics that really help people
have leadership impact no matter what
they aspire to do or i love whoever said
that they want to build a company
that'll spread love in the world like
how do i find just that person who's got
the capability to spread love in the
world so i'd say that's the second thing
that we're looking for is this evidence
that you will go out and impact the
world in a positive way and then third
and really important for stanford so i'm
reminded of this often our community is
small what you'll hear our alumni and
students and faculty say
is that it's a place where
in silicon valley where our goal is to
lift everyone up it's to fail and fail
often but to really um
be thinking beyond one's self and so i'm
looking when i read applications to to
find evidence of and to ask you data
about
um
how
i'm hoping to see that you will come and
strengthen our community
that that you will be someone who again
will make us um
will not only develop themselves but
help in the development of others and
and you can do that in so many ways but
that's what's special about stanford is
we're all working together and i think
it's special about innovation and
entrepreneurship you know in the valley
the ecosphere we come from is really um
that we solve things with each other you
can't do it alone so i'd say well those
at the very top are my goals
and then it's not um
it's not surprising that when we publish
on the web what we look for it maps to
that you'll see and i'm sure if you've
attended to another session we talk
about intellectual vitality that's
engagement what you'd be like in the
classroom we talk about demonstrated
leadership potential which is really the
past impact you've had so what have you
done out there in the world that we can
look to and then personal qualities and
contributions so how have you gone
through the world you know what what
what are your values um the choices
you've made how you've shown up to and
from that we're looking at what that
would mean for you to come to our
community and help us be stronger yeah
and like um there's been a phrase that i
used once and somehow it's stuck uh
background agnostic context dependent oh
i love that
folks out there yeah
a little bit more but i know in the past
i've had questions from people like i'm
from a non-traditional background or i'm
from you know ex like how do i
demonstrate right and so as you think
about intellectual vitality like that
can come in so many different facets of
your life and for us it doesn't matter
where it shows up um we celebrate it
where it does um and and then context
right like how it's gonna show up maybe
in that individual who's a consultant it
might look very different from someone
who's helping lead a family business so
just know that for folks out there like
it is about you and like the world
around you
and um would it be helpful to even go
one level deep deeper on that will and
explain so so dive down i i love that
you brought up that one first this
intellectual vitality because if um with
the other ones it might be easier it's
easier for us to say well that's what
we're looking for so then when we built
the application where do you as a
applicant demonstrate those things but i
always find the intellectual vitality
almost the hardest because you can find
it anywhere and i think um one of the
misses we're just looking at gpa and
test scores in reality we're looking for
evidence that
you've had
interesting ideas you know fundamentally
what leaders do if we think about that
leaders are influencing others to
collaborate towards a common goal and
part of that may be having a good idea
about how to solve a problem so it could
be just as much in the day-to-day work
that you're having now where you thought
of something someone else hadn't or
someone shared an idea and you jumped on
it to help that team move in just a
little different direction i mean i
would say intellectual vitality will
gets the gold star on our team this week
because this is a great example of us
just talking as an institution as a team
and saying hey we want to be more
transparent how can we really be helpful
in beginning to see a new way that we
might do something so we'd love to see
in your application it might come from
your references it might come in your
short answers it might come from the
kinds of things you studied on your
transcript but those are all places
where you can demonstrate that you're um
curious and engaged and and thinking and
about new ways to do things
yeah and as we're talking about things
popping up across kind of the whole
application um just the concept of the
holistic review process we've talked
i've talked a lot about it this week i
think people have heard my explanation
for it but it would be really nice to
hear how you articulate and understand
the holistic review process i know i've
talked about
the application and each section is like
a part of the picture and each helps us
understand like
who you might be in our classroom and
community um and things are jud like
we're making assessments on the whole
and not just on any one piece like how
how would you explain it to someone if
they ask you what is the holistic review
process
i think you just heat it up well well
and that you can't make a decision on
any applicant from just a part of the
application but i also it's easy to be
up here and i know many schools say
holistic and just go what does that mean
you know tell me more about that so i
think if you if we go back to what i
just said about the goals that we're
looking for someone who's engaged in the
class who's done positive things in
their community and also will help to
you know make a positive community
wherever they are like that's those
should be your guiding north but they
will we have to look across
your essays which are going to really
it'll shed light on who you are and the
choices you've made and what you care
about as well as our short answers which
tells us like what you have done
and then looking at some of the other
as i said for intellectual vitality we
can find it in different places
we are looking like a heat-seeking
missile through all of this as we read
um
and there's no like i was laughing well
as i was um thinking about our talk
today
if someone asked me like how do you read
an application i feel like every time i
read an application it's different
because as i'm going through maybe i'll
start with the with your biographical
information i'll immediately have a
question that comes up and i'll maybe it
is about intellectual vitality and i'll
jump to your transcript or over so i'd
be happy to share a little bit more
about how that works but the point is
it's holistic you need all of these
parts in order to come up with a good
assessment at the end of the day
there have been a lot of questions that
will process so
i wanted to direct make sure that we
spent some time today too so this is
kind of like the perfect segue awesome
people have been curious about the
process so any light that you could shed
into it and then
understanding like okay to what extent
is understanding our process
valuable versus like how can we
focus our energy such that we can show
up our best selves in the application
so that's a great question and i maybe i
can give some examples even of how i
read applications to bring it more to
life but at the top at the top level
what we're um what the admissions team
all the admissions officers and i are
trying to do is we're trying to give you
real estate so that you can tell your
whole story and we've even given you
these optional questions to make sure
you have enough space to do it so rest
assured we're going to be considering
that in its entirety and for each person
you might want to use that space in a
little bit of a different way but don't
think that there's more important
information put in one place or another
because it will vary so much by person
so i would not get hung up at all about
how is kirsten going to read my
particular application i would be
thinking much more about how can i make
sure that she knows you know that i'm
curious she knows about my stories i'm
most proud of the impact you know what
i've done and also she knows who i am
as a person he or she i should say
okay if i when i read applications i'll
try to think of some examples
um with real examples and i've read
thousands so hopefully this will be easy
it will
so usually we'll start at the very
beginning of the application you're
going to fill out just to get a sense of
who you are
in terms of where you're born and where
you're going to school and some of that
biographical information but oftentimes
even from there i'm taking leaps into
other parts of the application so for
instance maybe i'm getting that you
where you went to school and what you
studied and you studied classics and
then i see oh you're at citibank and
that'll be like wow how did that happen
and before i want to learn more about
citibank i'll probably jump to your
transcript and say what did you study
did you have any finance or quant
courses
because holistic to use your phrase um
the way that you perform or what you
worked on at city may be very different
from someone in the beginning at least
of your career than someone who spent
four years as a business or economics
major so that might be a good example of
how you know we're constantly asking
ourselves questions or
you know maybe if i see in your in that
information about college that you paid
for a significant part of your college
or that you're first gen i might
immediately jump to your essay then
think wow that must have been really
hard were there other things in your
context that um and how you've grown up
that might um shed light or a lens on
the choices you've made or the
transcript or your you know the classes
that you've taken all of that so it'll
be really you know individual for each
each person but i would think about
telling us from your perspective how can
you be most strategic to answer those
goals those three goals i gave you
was that helpful will
help me out here
and i think that also starts to come
into like there's a question from bruce
about the mission and values um that the
admissions committee holds and what
guides our decision making process and i
think for us it is that understanding
and
not just the projection of ideas and
notions but also evidence so every time
we're reading we're looking for in the
application oh here's where um
intellectual vitality like some form of
intellectual vitality might come to life
and maybe it is in your your writing
maybe it's in a letter of reference so i
think that evidence piece of it kind of
on the tactical practical the better
folks are able to articulate not just
the what but the how i think that that's
one of those um on the practical side of
things that help guide us and okay let
let's make a coherent yes look to admit
kind of decision yeah evidence
we're looking for those patterns of
evidence and i want to caution
as you're thinking about in the next
five weeks putting together for those of
you who are thinking first around
putting together your application i love
what will said about being agnostic
about where you've done it in the
context what i would start with is what
when we think about especially that
demonstrated leadership potential piece
what are the things that you've done in
your life that you're most proud of so
if we get to sit together tomorrow we're
having a cup of coffee
and i and i get to ask you the question
you know bruce tell me about a time that
you've had an impact that was meaningful
to you
really thinking what have i done that
i've worked on not what's important to
kirsten because i speak over and over
with prospects who think that they
needed to be the president of the
student body or
you know they needed to go to a certain
school or a certain kind of company and
the reality is
going back to that last example if
you're the first person in your family
was able to go to college or you ended
up having to pay for a third of your
college to me that's leadership that's
persistence that's grit that's taking
risks that's showing initiative so if
you start with yourself because you
understand your contacts better than any
of us could and don't project what we
want to hear what have you been working
really hard on and i believe each of us
has some stories that are powerful and
just making sure at least for stanford
we can't speak for other schools but at
stanford that's that's where we're
seeing you know leadership come to light
and so as we're talking about like the
application and how we can put our best
foot forward i this whole week has been
about tips advice best practices so is
it okay if we go in that direction
kirsten
okay knowing that between the two of us
yeah thousands of applications
and even talking to our teammates right
i i want to say there's at least
a century of admissions experience um
if not more yeah
hopefully some of our observations come
with you know
some backing there um but this week we
split even our workshops into um how do
you start your story how do you
communicate it in the written format and
then when it comes to speaking because
speaking is also going to be not just
part of the application process but a
consistent part of the
journey throughout so maybe starting at
that start in your store so for folks
who might be thinking about business
school or really trying to put together
like the threads and the details of
maybe why like do you have any tips or
advice for folks and things that they
might consider
um
as they're come pulling together like
the rationale for business school or for
stanford
so that why stanford question is that
what you're speaking about yeah or just
yeah just broadly as people are
preparing so yeah
um
really when i think about the essays and
short answers you're writing for me they
fall into those two camps which is what
have you done and we just talked about
that that would be really starting with
what are you proud of the impact that
you've
had and i'm going to pause there again
too because this impact could be very um
individual to you as well you know maybe
you're a violinist and you've worked
really hard and you performed in
ensembles or in symphonies like that may
be the way that you're going to
demonstrate leadership to us or maybe
it's in
you know your church or your mosque or
with your family helping them there's so
many ways that you can show that but
think about what you've done that's
where i would start first and reflect
and and jot down and i use three stories
because i want you to kind of um
see have a chance to play with that and
brainstorm think outside of the box
because it may be something that you're
proud of that you wouldn't necessarily
have left off
led with if that makes sense so that's
part a the second part that we talked
about was how you've walked through life
who you are as a person what are your
values and motivations and our essay
about what matters most and why it gets
to the absolute heart and it's probably
one of the hardest essays you're likely
to answer that's the that's the hard
news for me um
that gets to
i think one of the easy you've probably
gotten a lot of advice but for me
personally if i had to put in my two
cents on that if you could look back
over the last you know since college for
many of you that's eight years you've
made choices you've decided what to
major in you've decided what
extracurricular activities you've been
involved in you've decided um what types
of organizations to work for post
potentially if you have had work
experience and at the time you may not
have thought very much about why you're
making these choices but now you have an
opportunity to go back and connect the
dots and see what those themes are i
know i was working or speaking with a
candidate recently and they're telling
me about what they had done in college
and they had been
an r.a in their college dorm they had
been a ta for a teacher and some courses
they'd done that twice they had signed
up to be a wellness counselor and
immediately we're seeing this theme that
whether it was in academics or in living
situations or even on the wellness side
of just helping people develop and grow
and that's like well there you go you
know that's a big aha so maybe you can
look over your choices and think about
what's been important to you and why
you've made them and you'll start to
understand you know what what those
deeper values are
so that's why
that would be the advice i'd give on the
essay as well yeah there was a um
kind of preparation uh
tip
process that i shared with people
remember reflect process connect um just
remember the things you did yeah reflect
on like the circumstances around it
process like how did that kind of
matter and why was it significant and
then connect the dots between the
different parts of your life and how
might it informed your journey um so
hopefully i was trying to
put it in a catchy phrase that people
could remember if they're like okay
if i need to sit down what's an easy way
to think and prepare about with some of
the things that i've done so kind of
plug in that pneumonia yeah i'd love it
i totally love it i love your new mama
because i'm going to steal that next
time i'm in another group
maybe what's also important is to go
back to the why like why does stanford
ask this question we've been asking it
at least for two decades and i'm not
going to change it so if you're going to
apply in a year or two you'll still have
the luxury of doing this question
there has been
tremendous research on looking at
leaders later in their journey
what was
what prompted their impact or prompted
the results that they were able to
achieve and one of the distinctions that
we see is leaders who know what their
values are and can speak to their
motivations tend to use that as the
energy to take risks and to take
initiative so we're looking for you to
see
to reflect on what could those
motivations be and that will help you
guide help guide yourself in the future
now will and i are not going to evaluate
what values you have so this is a
projective question for us it's more
about your self-awareness and reflection
and knowing who you are and could be as
a leader so that when you come to
stanford you're ready to take advantage
of all the opportunities we have here
and and go ahead we'll sorry yeah no
it's almost like you're kick-starting
that leadership development and
leadership curriculum because there's so
much
introspection that's required to answer
you know why should someone follow you
or why should someone want to follow you
to be even more um precise um i really
appreciate the question i've i've
mentioned it before like i often use it
as a kind of
way to make decisions when i'm at pivot
points in life even so even beyond the
application i think in
embracing the process of applying there
are some greater learnings that can be
had which yeah
oftentimes and the way i grew up it's
like you apply for a thing
and then that's it whereas in this
process there's also it's an invitation
for greater learnings that i never
realized could have been part of
something like applying to school before
yeah and i love that and it's also our
second essay why stanford what are your
aspirations and how will you get there
it's the same
um it's we're asking you on the one hand
to look back at what your motivations
were and then to use those to tell us
what you might be interested in
working on or solving in in your future
i think it's worth saying and this is
different uh than other schools so i
really want to make sure we're just
speaking for stanford we don't have
career services sitting on our
admissions committee we really believe
if you get into stanford that you are
capable of what of achieving whatever
dreams and aspirations you have that
won't happen necessarily immediately
maybe there are pivots or expertise you
have to gain but we know that you'll get
there so you should feel free to write
about whatever you want in those
aspirations and we also know
that those are going to change the vast
majority of our students think they'll
do something when they come in and we'll
do something very different when they
graduate and that's okay too so again
this is a question to say have you
thought enough about what you care about
that you can have a true north even
though it might shift west or east and
you'll go through this journey but we're
really curious about um at this moment
in time what's important to you and and
what would you like to work on
yeah because even if it's not the first
thing after there's probably going to be
at least a few pivots in your lifetime
this is just one stop in a a
career and life basically that extends
beyond um yes you will take the memories
and community and the learnings from the
gsb with you but it's really to empower
you to be able to thrive regardless of
your um circumstance and situation i
think
yeah
all right and then we do so we often
talk a lot about the writing the essays
an area that i i know we both find
fascinating i
that we don't get to talk too much about
is the interview um and i know you have
a
really rich history and assessment can
you talk us through
um like the stanford behavioral-based
interview any advice that you might give
for folks and how to think about um you
know what it looks like
yeah
yes
well if you
for us we will interview somewhere
between 10 to 15 of our applicants so if
you get the email inviting you to
interview congratulations that's a
wonderful step in the process
our interviews are done by alumni across
the globe so they'll have your resume um
and not your whole application so it's
your chance to share with them in a
little bit more detail their story but
let's go back to your question will why
do we structure the way our interviews
in the way that we do they're
behavioral-based structural interviews
and what they're meant to do is to
really take you know this application
which is in a flat piece of paper to
bring it to life it's your opportunity
to really bring it to living color
and we basically will ask you the same
questions that you're answering in your
short answers tell us about a time
you've had an impact that was meaningful
or tell us about a time you've had a
challenge tell us about a time you've
worked on a team
and notice that tell us about a time
language that's very typical of
behavioral-based interviews for those of
you who have not done them
what we're trying to do here is
we believe that your past behavior will
predict future behavior so you had an
opportunity in your application and the
essays are short answers to tell us
about some of those stories that you
think are important and you're proud of
but when we're reading an application we
don't have a chance to probe and really
bring those to life so um what could be
a good example
to really
i'm gonna play this is an interview will
that really make this concrete and the
why behind what we're trying to do here
let's say that um many of our applicants
come from finance maybe you were asked
to help
build a training program or launch a new
initiative on training for new analysts
that are coming in and you write you
give us a short answer question about
that maybe 200 words so that's a really
exciting
leadership i'd call it impact moment but
maybe your interviewer as your when he
asks you a question like tell me about a
time you've taken initiative you lead
with this example and the interviewer
might want to know oh well how many
students attended that or how long was
the training program or how did you get
permission to even to do it or the
resources or did you you know how did
you develop the curriculum so all of
these things we may or may not have been
able to ask you about in a flat
application but in your interview you
can bring it to life
and i think
so these interviews in some ways you
won't have a lot of additional
preparation because you've already been
thinking about those important stories
but i want to make sure because i i do
some of the interviews as well
one
potential um what i call it or a tip
something to avoid
is make sure when you come to your
interview you know that you're the hero
and heroes can be humble so as you come
in really think about what was the
situation you know you saw there was a
problem and that um new analysts weren't
getting the training they needed
what did you do about it so what actions
did you as an individual take
why was that important you know why was
that meaningful to the organization so
what happened from it and be willing to
step in that and be be the hero um and
again heroes can be humble but you still
need to own this was what i did um in
this initiative so that's the best way i
think you could prepare for our
interviews i was laughing because i
thought you were going to ask me to like
demo with you i'm glad we didn't we did
yes i did i did uh improv yesterday yeah
one of the um tips i shared yesterday
and kind of ingest in the phrasing
there's no i and t but there is an admit
i was joking but yeah the point was even
in a group setting there's something
that you might have done as an
individual and there's something you did
do as an individual to help advance
something from point a to point
absolutely
for a lot of us it's hard to shift out
of that we mentality um and embrace and
like really center yourself i know there
was a i remember one of our interviews
kirsten oh no even having done
interviews myself you were like will
you keep saying we
what did you do
and even though it was an example i knew
like you were actually involved and i
was like oh wait so definitely
it's a real thing and we encourage you
and we want to know about you so just
we invite you to center yourself in your
anecdotes
that's fantastic advice absolutely right
and oftentimes it took a group to get
things done but just like you said will
you were you were taking actions that
helped that group so speak to those yeah
and um
if we do probe it's because we want to
learn more and we're trying to help you
get towards some of the detail that will
be helpful for us as we understand your
application as a whole
and the other thing is um
we are blessed on our team
um carrie oliver has been running our
interviews for a long time she's trained
hundreds of alumni across the globe they
love to participate and come back every
year so a part of this too is just to
meet someone who really cares about
stanford and who wants to get to know
you and you them so once you're done
with behavioral based part of the
interview there will be a wonderful
moment at the end where you can ask some
questions learn more about stanford and
that's again just the time to be
yourself relax
develop rapport get to know someone new
yeah carrie has been such a gift to the
program like it has really shined i
think in the you know recent years
kind of shifting away from the
application now so we've kind of moved
through the process like how do you
think about it how do you prepare we
talked about essays that interview which
is that next step um as part of the
holistic process but again this is just
one step along the journey and
you know we want to make sure that
you're going to thrive at business
school so having seen so many journeys
through uh do you have any tips for
folks who
to help them
hit the ground running once they're at
school and really maximize the
opportunity kind of with a notion that
like also
as you're preparing for business school
that's also you know during that that's
what we're looking for in the
application process as well so how can
someone actually set themselves up for
long-term success and really think about
the big picture here not just the
application yeah
well it's so easy to get caught up with
all these deadlines coming and essays
and everything else to just speak i
gotta get this done
we have designed our process to try to
help you
reflect and be prepared for business
school
one thing i may say is this is
most of you in the audience have had i'm
guessing you went to college
had that experience now you've been
working for several years and there's
been more of a path about what do i have
to do to succeed and this is probably
one of the first times in your life
where there are no more boxes to check
necessarily you know the world is open
for you to figure out what do you care
about what do you want to work on what's
your own you know how you're going to
find energy to to show up every day and
be excited about what you're doing so
it's a great as you think about this
transition your job as you're coming to
business school is not to
um obviously to do well in the classroom
and get involved but it's also to really
uncover for yourself
what will be most important to you when
you graduate to begin working on and
there are so many opportunities at
stanford and at other schools for you to
sample whatever expertise you want to
develop and it's across disciplines for
us so it could be in any of the graduate
schools whether you have an interest in
healthcare education or policy the world
is an oyster so i hope during this time
and over the summer as you transition
one of the things you can do is begin to
think what would be my priorities what
do i want to learn more about what do i
want to
dive into even though i know that will
evolve so when the world is completely
open i have some way to prioritize what
could be most important to me so i i'd
say coming up with a list of what those
you know what's in your probably what
what um are your aspirations that's
probably helping you to get that list so
that's one to rest
what we hear from folks coming in our
first term is the classes are are hard
and they take a lot of time and there's
all the social things happening so
really knowing even though some of you
may be in roles right now where you work
extra hard i've heard from folks in
finance they work weekends and all of
this but i've heard from those same
students when they come in that it was
just as intensive that those first few
terms here in a different way maybe a
little more fun at times but certainly
intensive
but also another tip is look at your
quantitative preparation and as an
applicant as well
so
we will some of you have had lots of
exposure to that in the past for those
of you who haven't if you haven't taken
statistics or economics micro macro
economics or calculus
those will be core skills that you i
shouldn't say calculus necessarily but
some kind of higher level math those are
going to be skills here that you'll need
to rely on even in that first term so
before you're applying if you notice
that you
have not had some of that class work you
might want to speak in additional
information about what kind of prep you
will be getting something like an mba
math could be helpful but you want to
make sure when you get here you have
some understanding of the fundamentals
of those topics
and then i think last and my most
favorite thing to say is
we
we get so excited will and i about
getting you to stanford and and kind of
falling in love with your application
and we can't wait to meet you
uh you also if you're selected there's
so few spots i guess i would say there's
a responsibility to think about how
you're going to also as a leader show up
and help build this community and it's
never too early you know you cannot
start over the summer think about your
classes you want to take but also what's
going on in campus and what problems or
not problems i should say but what are
some of the ways that you can become
part of the community in a deep way and
that often means stepping in and taking
initiative to support others help others
so i'd love for you if i could give that
advice to be thinking in the summer and
actually it's whatever program you go to
that this is a chance to
start your own sort of personal
leadership journey and begin to help and
um build others up over the next two
years in a really safe place
that will
and those kinds of commitments and
investments will last again over a
lifetime you'll be part of the stanford
community for 40 years or 50 as long as
you're you know as long as you're live
so whatever connections and investment
you're making now will pay dividends for
all of us in the future yeah and i want
to add maybe one more like we're talking
about we want you to succeed and thrive
and that also means it's okay to ask for
help like whether it is academic help
because you might have been high school
for a while and it's a different type of
engagement and intensity than maybe in
your work life
so it might be academic help there's
academic support there's career help
there's also counseling and
psychological services help knowing that
this is going to be a really intensive
demanding experience on multiple fronts
and sometimes it it helps to have
someone to talk to who gets it and can
help guide you through the process so
it's okay to ask for help we want you to
ask for help and there are multiple
spaces that can be support networks to
make sure that maybe even if it's not
the journey you thought it would be we
are still making progress and moving
towards whatever goal it is you have so
um i just want to make sure that's also
risen to the top here great great well
yeah and then kind of
full circle like
people are on campus we have students i
know sometimes folks say like you know
nobody gets in we have a class um like
we say sometimes the only surefire way
to not get admitted is to not apply um
but to that effect like what are some of
the reasons you've heard from admitted
students about why they almost didn't
apply what like what were some of the
things that held them back and then you
know ultimately they made it through
it is
remarkable will and i don't know if it's
because we all are have imposter
syndrome at some level all of us is just
deep in our hearts but when i come to
admit weekend it seems like one of the
most common refrains as i get to meet
all our new students is you know kirsten
i almost didn't apply they start with
that and and it's for so many different
reasons so even for those who are
admitting in the class there's this
feeling that it felt
they had to be courageous
to be able to share what we're asking
and actually hit that submit button but
for me it could be um sometimes people
say well i was from consulting or
finance and everybody applies from those
i just didn't think i'd stick out or
someone else will say i'm not from
consulting or not from finance so you're
not going to want to read my application
so even that is funny or
you know i didn't study business so i
didn't know whether or not i would fit
in or you would be interested
or i went to a community college or a
state college not an ivy league so i
didn't think i would have a shot
um what else or we have one conversation
i remember he was a pastor he's like you
wouldn't believe that i really wanted to
be a business person so whatever
whatever your imposter is telling you
that little gremlin voice
know that um none of these would be
reasons not to apply and many of the
things i just talked to would add to
kind of the diversity of your
perspective in our class would be
something we would look at as a positive
not a negative a positive that you
started at a community college and were
able to you know perhaps transfer or be
able to
graduate in the first place so just
don't um stop yourself because you're
the only one who can really hit that
submit button yeah take that strength
race strength based approach here's what
i contribute this is who i am i love it
share that with us
because then doors really do open
and imagine i mean imagine
me listening to and i say that it's a
common reframe how many students i'm
like what if all what if these students
had not applied it would be i think not
only a tragedy for us in our in our
class but also the future of you know
our world in some ways because we're
really relying on you to go out and
create this positive impact so
you're early in your career the time is
now to try to to share yourself and take
that risk
yeah all right so we do have some time
left i want to make sure we do um jump
into that q a box um so here's the one
of the top voted questions from yanan um
and this is a question about like when
it comes down to two individuals or two
files like
if there's a close match like how do we
think through the decision-making
process
and maybe even just taking it beyond
like
the hypothetical of we just have two
like what again just to kind of go over
some of the things we talked about at
the beginning what are some of the
things that folks can kind of make sure
that they're thinking through to put
their best foot forward
yeah hey will i'm gonna this is an
awesome question and i've been doing a
lot of the talking so i'm gonna switch
gears and say how about you take a first
shot and i'll take a second because i
wonder if we're even a little different
and how we might yeah i mean
this is one of those times where
it helps to know that there is a
committee right and it's not just one
individual who's making the decision
there's multiple folks who are both
taking a look at the individual as well
as the wholeness of the class um and the
decision-making process is going to
actually change year to year based on
the context of that class so it for me
it's hard to
make a
clear like
x
these are the things we look for because
there's so many different elements
involved like it is the holistic review
process
um
so that is kind of my non-answer answers
yeah it is a again and it's a tough
question i know
in a will is right that the decisions
are made within the admissions committee
so it's not just the one voice who's
looking at any application i know for me
though sometimes i'm trying to make even
when i'm looking at my own pool and
trying to make recommendations on
candidates there might be two who feel
very close that's part of our job i tend
to go back in and i'll use what will
said before like for this evidence we
know what our criteria are and where
i'll really go back into the application
again and remind myself of where i've
seen intellectual vitality remind myself
of the kind of impact someone has had or
you know who they are as a person and
that helps ground me and and oftentimes
both individuals could be really
fabulous candidates so i want everyone
to know too you know i advise to go wide
on your mba applications because luck
isn't maybe the best word to use but
i we have far more we have many more
candidates than we could put in one
class so hopefully that makes you feel
better that it's never like oh i'll just
take this one you know it's always like
okay i need to go in and really make
sure that this is the right decision on
the same token though at any given
moment on application you know could be
looked at in different ways by different
people so you guys get the
the chance to
um try to apply to multiple places yeah
and there's a question here that i i'll
actually take kristin if it's okay
danielle
about we haven't seen the whole team um
but the idea of representation is
something that uh they think about
um
but also things that other
underrepresented uh folks from
underrepresented backgrounds
um that you know it's really important
to have representation so they feel
comfortable in the application process
um i see you all are currently hiring an
assistant director for outreach and
diversity how have you all committed to
ensuring underserved communities have
access to a degree program like this and
so uh and you're you're hiring actually
so send your resume it will yeah that's
great
that's actually my old goal and i think
that's one of the beautiful things about
our office is that
even though i might be stepping out of
that position i've i'm now like leading
this team
that doesn't mean that i stop doing that
job so now i'm able to help coach mentor
and support whoever takes on that role
and now there's multiple people
programs like application week and
really shifting the way that we think
about our programming so that rather
than just telling you about the the
school but
giving tools and frameworks for better
understanding of the application process
i like to think of that as closing that
equity gap
that piece of equity being like the
knowledge of how to apply sometimes it
can feel like a black box and if you
don't know anybody who hasn't gone
through it before who has gone through
it before you know who do you turn to
for help and so that's one of the things
i find so
empowering and motivating about working
in this office and being able to work
with kirsten is that we think a lot
about how can we make sure this process
is as open accessible and equitable as
possible um and so uh danielle please
know to everybody out there we take this
very seriously and we are looking to
support everyone out there so that you
know you can all have a fair shot and
opportunity to attend a school like
stanford or any other institution that
you hope to go to so just wanted to put
that plug in there yeah and and we'll
all jump in thank you for asking that
really important question danielle
i also look to the senior leadership of
all of stanford as well as the gsb and
it is the
one of the highest priorities of the
school right now to make sure that our
classes represent the diversity that's
out there in our communities and for me
to have the honor of holding this
position we do take that very seriously
and um hopefully you've seen on our web
we've been much more transparent about
the backgrounds and the identities of
the students that are coming in and
trying um with that with the
opportunities like this and will's uh
broad shoulders and his teams and many
other on our team trying to increase the
number of people in our pipelines of
people who apply so that we can continue
to make progress and we have made some
pretty dramatic progress even in the
last three years in the diversity of our
class and are going to continue to fight
whether it's gender ethnicity i mean all
different kinds of diversity so
the fact that you're here is a really
phenomenal sign and we're glad you're
part of the audience today and hopefully
these and other efforts will continue to
make us successful on that front because
that's my job i want the boardrooms of
tomorrow to look like what our
communities are not to look like what
they've looked in the past
all right kristen we have
the time flew by we have a couple of
minutes yeah we can close out with some
advice words of wisdom or or words of
encouragement that you have for the
group um i think that would be an
amazing way to close out application
week all right i will do this though
we'll only if you will close after my
clothes because i really you are one of
the heroes of this week i have such
appreciation so it'd be wonderful you do
the final wrap is that fair okay
all right
all right so um
i do this job fundamentally because i
believe that each of us has potential
and many times we aren't given the
resources the confidence um even the
self-narrative to know what we're
capable of and one of the things that
i'm most proud about at stanford is i
think our program is designed to help
people understand who they are and again
get that confidence to really dream big
and then upon graduation take you know
the risk to make that happen so for
anyone out in the audience who who does
have things they believe that they're
capable of that are bigger than
themselves and for anyone out there who
might feel like oh but you know i don't
know
it's time to take a step and you know we
put on this
application week four for you if you
don't believe in yourself and begin
there no one else can or will but know
that will and myself and the rest of our
admissions team is looking forward to
learning more about you to honoring you
and no matter what happens it is a step
for you to start owning what you're
capable of so good luck and i can't wait
to learn more about you
and you will
so bring us home
i think stanford is a place
where people see possibility they see
possibility in themselves in each other
the way that we're going to be able to
tackle the world's biggest problems it's
like yes we can and we're going to do
this together
um and i think this is encapsulated on
the um cornerstone so i don't have the
inscription uh up in front of me so
hopefully i get it right
but it's um dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet and to the people
who are about to dream them up this is a
place that's dedicated to you your
dreams your ideas the things that you
want to do the things that haven't
happened yet that you might be the
pioneer of whether it is a new field or
maybe just the pioneer of tackling that
new that little problem that you've had
that's been bugging you and now let's
look at it from a new direction
this is a place where we want you to
dream big lead boldly
um so if there's one thing that i could
say to all of you it's um dream big
y'all thank you so much for joining us
we hope you had a great time this week i
know i did
and we'll hope to see you soon take care
and from the stanford graduate school of
business we hope you have a wonderful
rest of the day and we hope to see your
application soon
[Music]